david zobda bonjour bonjour bonjour aux
auditeurs de mardi première est la
matière en particulier
et oui merde la ville de lamentin depuis
novembre 2018 succédant ainsi à pierre
samot qui a démissionné de sa fonction
en cours de mandat comme il l'avait
indiqué qu'il le ferait après avoir été
réélu en 2014
vous étiez david zobda déjà son premier
adjoint au début de ce mandat de six ans
qui va s'achever dans quelques semaines
alors certains vont dire que c'est donc
en toute logique que vous vous retrouvez
candidat cette fois à votre propre
succession
cela vous aurait été difficile de faire
autrement c'est exact c'est tout à fait
ça et vous avez parfaitement résumé la
situation qui à sa moc amené la ville de
la montée pendant trente années et qui
considère qu'il est temps pour lui de
passer la main nous avions déjà convenu
que je pourrai assumer son remplacement
donc depuis le 20 novembre 2018 je suis
maire de la ville du lamentin
il est donc logique que je me présente à
ma propre succession mais aussi à celle
de bien çà mau puisque je suis dans la
continuité de cette action que à
laquelle j'ai moi même participé
je suis dans cette filiation toutes les
municipalités laventinois est ce qu'il
n'ya pas un inconvénient peut-être là
pour vous et votre équipe parce qu'ils
auraient pas une forme de l'usure du
pouvoir de la longévité des deux de
cette équipe là non pas du tout alors
évidemment l'équipe doit être renouvelée
c'est normal il faut la rajeunir il faut
la renouveler il faut offrir une autre
perspective
et puis une présence de nouvelle
génération sur la liste que je que je
vais conduire
mais au-delà de ça je ne suis pas dans
l'usure du pouvoir puisque je n'ai pas
était maire depuis ce rejet était le
premier en belgique j'ai collaboré avec
pierre samot et j'assume en toute
solidarité tout ce que la ville du
lamentin a réussi de bien est ce que la
ville d'une à mater les filles de moyens
éventuellement mais je suis j'assume
toutes ces missions là je le disais je
suis dans la filiation au jurassien
pierre samot la légitimité de ma
candidature n'est plus à lyon mais je
posais une question sur l'usure du
pouvoir de
d'une équipe vous avez dit que qu'elle a
été grandement renouvelée peut-être pas
grandement d'ailleurs partiellement
cassé marolleau mais vous savez les yeux
de pouvoir se justifier ou se lit en
fonction de sa capacité à travailler ou
pas en un an
j'ai beaucoup faire j'ai beaucoup fait
j'ai montré aux lames anti noir qu'il ya
encore beaucoup de choses à faire au
lamentin et que je suis dans l'action
je suis dans la réalisation je m'occupe
des situations je gère des problèmes au
quotidien et surtout je suis dans
l'anticipation et donc vous êtes aussi
vous êtes aussi candidat pour donner un
nouvel alan stivell élan même comme on
dit en créole le ballon à mahler
lamentin c'est très clair je ne suis pas
candidat à la mairie du lamentin pour la
gérer simplement
j'entends d'ici là ici et là quelques
candidats qu'ils annoncent qu'ils vont
refaire des routes qui vont changer d
éclairage etc
c'est très bien et ça c'est la gestion
que tout le monde fait est que la ville
du lamentin fait depuis des décennies
moi ce que je veux c'est diriger cette
vie lui donner un cap lui donner un
projet que les jeux de l'amandinois qui
m'écoutait le sentiment que notre ville
soit va vers une ville de demain une
ville tournée vers l'avenir avec des
projets des perspectives offertes
brunette les soins et la fierté
l'amandinoise il continue à garder dans
cette ville un dynamisme une force une
puissance qui qui la positionne comme
étant l'une des villes phares de notre
pays
en tout cas la valeur d'exemple et de
modèle et je voudrais que la ville du
lamentin part subi ce projet ambitieux
que nous portons sont de nature à garder
sa place dans l'échiquier martinique
quel est le projet qui vous tient
particulièrement à coeur david zobda
pour les lames anti noise et et la monty
nous a juste il ya de nouveaux projets
en tout cas jax notre programme sur
quatre 4 piliers le premier pilier
évidemment c'est l'aménagement du
territoire le projet territorial qui
sera fondé d'abord sur les les
centralités de quartier d identité de
quartier le bien-être le bien vivre dans
nos quartiers et ensuite sur un grand
projet un vaste projet qui va moderniser
le centre ville du lamentin
c'est le projet coeur de ville qui va
rebooster le centre ville du lamentin
ont créé une animation économique en
développant les pôles d'attractivité que
son l'entrée de ville ducale bassi et la
friche de l'ancien hôpital de la matin
deux pôles de développement qui vont
faire de l'attractivité du territoire
ensuite le deuxième pilier c'est
évidemment le ministre
cal avec un véritable plan social
territorial que faisons nous pour les
personnes âgées
quelle est la stratégie le plan pour la
jeunesse la précarité de logements
insalubres et c'était les pauvretés
troisième pilier le champ associatif sur
lequel la puissance publique doit
pouvoir s'appuyer pour développer le
sport la culture etc ont fait le
quatrième pilier qui fait la force du
lamentin c'est le développement
économique
le rapprochement avec les puissances
économiques a précisé nomination de
simon je voulais vous interrogez le
support d'une cure puisque vous avez
participé à un déjeuner débat sur le
thème la ville du lamentin poumon
économique de la martinique un déjeuner
débat organisé par contact entreprises
quel est votre rapport avec justement
alors je vais pas dire le monde des
affaires parce que c'est un peu connoté
ça pourrait être interprété
mais avec le monde des entreprises j'ai
d'économique de la martinique j'avais
axé leurs rapports avec le monde
économique parce que la ville de
l'inventaire a toujours était qui a
longtemps été une musicalité communiste
on le rappelle bien entendu qui se
revendiquait telle qu'elle est toujours
de gauche ont bâti rebâtir et de cette
filiation l'a donc ya pas d'antinomie de
gauche jamal dati domi il faut qu'il
faut bien savoir que le développement
économique fait partie de mes romans
deux pays
et l'idée c'est de savoir comment
utiliser le développement économiques
pour appuyer un développement social il
n'y a pas de développement social sans
développement économique et les 210
c'est pourquoi je veux renouer un
dialogue très puissant très fort avec le
tissu économique la matinée a créé ce
club des entreprises du lamentin et le
lien avec l'aéroport créé le les
conditions de l'émergence trouver de
nouvelles zones d'activités économiques
avec la casse m mais surtout créé ce
club pour qu'il y ait un retour
justement tous les lamas tilloy la casse
m une ambition pour la cacem personnel
non non pour l'inventaire oui merci
david zobda c'est moi qui vous remercie
l'émission réalisé par audrey calixte